Brazil is seeking to establish stronger
diplomatic ties with China and the visit
by Brazilian president
Silva to Beijing this week will formally
kick off this new phase of the bilateral
relationship
China looks forward to working with
Brazil to take president Lula's visit as
an opportunity to hold constructive
discussions on promoting the in-depth
development on bilateral economic and
trade relations
ahead of his trip president Lula
expressed a desire to work closely with
Beijing in mediating peace talks between
Russia and Ukraine
I am convinced that Brazil can make an
extraordinary contribution to putting an
end to the war and return to peace
though Brazil is not the only Latin
American country that's refrained from
taking sides on the Russia Ukraine
conflict president Lula has stood apart
from other Western leaders when it comes
to foreign policy the U.S and several
European countries expressed concerns
after president Lula applauded a recent
meeting between the Chinese and Russian
presidents in Moscow
and president Lula's decision to allow
Iranian warships to dock in Rio de
Janeiro last month also raised eyebrows
among Brazil's Western allies
foreign policy analysts however say
these actions don't fall out of line
with Brazil's tradition of diplomatic
non-alignment if anything it seems to
all be part of President Lula's desire
to take a more leading role on the
international stage
Lula is returning also to play a role in
global affairs
indianizations Brazil is is looking for
the expansion of the security Council uh
a number of members
Brazil will host the G20 next year is
beginning to prepare for that in 2009
China surpassed the U.S as Brazil's main
trading partner president Lula's visit
to Beijing could reposition Brazil as an
international power player which many
say deteriorated under Lula's
predecessor jaid bolsonaro recorder
we must remember that andalula the
bricks were founded which is a group of
emerging Powers including China Brazil
Russia India and South Africa to creates
a strategic balance over other world
powers
Brazil's Ministry of Foreign Affairs
says at least 20 bilateral agreements
are expected to be signed Manuel rapalo
Al Jazeera